Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill Burn?
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And Ah,
just check it in on you.
I'm just checking in on you.
How are you?
How's your week going?
My Week is going fed fucking tastic man.
I did my special,
I taped it.
It is done.
It's in the can as they say in my business and now just needs to be edited.
Some poor pastors got to look at the footage and try to put that mess together.
I want to thank everybody that came out to a Royal Albert Hall in London,
England.
I could not have had a better time.
Um,
I just,
it's just a couple of magical nights out there and hopefully it'll show up on
the digital recording that we made
somehow that it will,
that will be conveyed.
Um,
so now I have no act.
Okay.
And uh,
I was like,
you know what,
man,
I'm just going to stay away from the comedy clubs.
I'm just going to go live some life.
You've heard me all that yoga teachers,
Shit.
I was saying just going to go live some life and I'm going to let the next hour
come to me.
And I was literally thinking already tonight,
I've been back for fucking 24 hours being like,
maybe I'll go down to the club tonight,
Dan.
I just go fuck around.
Yeah,
no,
I,
I'm going to learn how to relax
man.
No down and just fucking eat an avocado or whatever the fuck it is.
You people do that,
know how to relax.
You guys fascinate me.
You people know how to relax.
You know what I mean?
Like you go to a hotel and you actually put on the robe,
right?
You get the slippers on and shit and then you fucking order room service and
you're eating chocolate strawberries from Sherry's berries.
Whatever the fuck it is.
Should do,
you know,
you have a spa day.
Okay.
Um,
I,
I know I'm making fun of it,
but I am fascinated
by that.
I want to be that guy,
that guy who knows how to fucking chill man,
because I don't know how to do it because this is what I do.
I go and I'm not doing fucking standup.
And then I go,
you know what I'm gonna do?
I'm gonna get fucking 20 hours in the air in a helicopter,
or I'm going to go fucking play drums for fucking 30 hours.
This my,
I just fill the time up.
You know,
you fucking people who could just sit on a porch.
You don't,
I can't do that unless some slowly killing myself,
booze or cigar,
you know,
I can't just sit on a fuck,
give it just walk by,
you know,
and one of these sleepy southern towns,
you know what I mean?
Where they still think like Lyndon Johnson was president,
right.
And you just walking down the fucking street and you just see somebody sitting
on a porch reading a book
and it's just,
you know,
that person,
they got it figured out.
You know what I mean?
They walk into church on Sunday with head held high.
They got nothing to confess.
The fuck did they do?
Huh?
What is it,
a big sin that they peaked a few pages forward,
hoping that there'd be an end of a chapter to give their eyes a break,
you know,
disrespecting the author and all the hard work that they put in.
Um,
yeah,
I'm going to try to fucking chill out here at least for three days.
I'm going to try to do,
uh,
nothing,
but I mean,
I also have a table read tomorrow for F is for family.
So that's something,
Eh,
uh,
whatever.
What are you gonna do,
you know,
having shit to do.
It's better than having nothing to do right around my fucking that up.
Was it?
Because at that fork in the road,
I chose boo boos rather than we'd,
you know,
the people who choose,
we'd,
they liked the people that like,
you know,
their dream in life is to retire,
and people who drink their dream in life is to tell people what to do and the
people go out and do it.
All right.
I'm paying with a broad brush here,
but that's what I do on this podcast.
All right?
None of this is fucking necessarily worked out.
You know,
there's the occasional goddamn setlist.
All right,
let's,
let's go.
You know what I always do when I go to put together a new hour is I have to go
topical.
Let's say what said the news?
Everybody.
R Kelly.
Okay.
Bobby Kelly.
My good,
my old roommate,
just plain [inaudible],
but the other r Kelly,
the singer,
right.
I'm trying to think of one of his fucking songs.
I used to know,
I used to know his songs.
Then they took the,
the videos away from MTV.
The like the last one I saw that he made was the one where he was sitting down
and he had half his head braided while someone was Braden is the other part of
his fucking head.
You know,
and God knows what happened to that poor woman judge it by that fucking debacle
of an interview.
Okay.
I
like,
he is,
he is
fucked.
That's all I got out of that.
I had not get a,
I am an innocent man accused of some shit that I didn't do.
What I,
the vibe from that is I am fucked.
Um,
they got me this time.
God,
it,
um,
yeah.
You know,
we know it's fucking hilarious when that guy was standing up screaming and
yelling and that woman just sat there,
right?
How that became the opportunity for other Douche bags on the Internet to try and
bring up some male female point,
you know,
to literally try to wedge.
They are fucking goddamn agenda.
We're literally talking about a guy who if this saying what he did,
if he did what they're,
say what he did,
this guy is a fucking monster.
This is about getting this fucking guy off of the god Damn Street before we can
do this as somebody else.
But these selfish fucking assholes on the Internet.
Nah,
Nah.
We're going to wet notice when he screams and yet,
and that reporter,
she just sat there so stoically so defiantly so private.
It's,
that's what they teach you.
They teach you that in journalism class.
What do think a guy would have stood up and fought them?
So then all these women pile on and they start telling these stories of sitting
quietly as their boyfriend punched the wall right next to their head.
These selfish fucking assholes took this moment in time,
a pedophile on alleged pedophile,
freaking the fuck out and all those victims.
Fuck all of them.
It's about you and whatever fucking went down during your fucking relationship
and how you were a total fucking victim.
You know what?
I got one thing to say to you guys,
ladies.
All right,
we'll,
we'll fucking get to you on this one.
This is about the women who actually were fucking a victim of this guy.
Stop trying to fucking,
you know,
you know what it's like.
It's like back in the day whenever I see stuff about hair metal bands and the in
the eighties on the sunset strip and you'd go up and you'd staple your fucking
banner,
you little flyer up to a telephone pole and then two seconds later somebody else
would staple.
There's over yours.
That's what the fuck is going on.
It even happens on shit like this.
It's so God damn shameless,
you know?
Okay
Lady,
she got to ask yourself something.
All right,
if more than one time a man in your life punches a hole in a wall right near
your head,
at any point,
is there any sort of self reflection where you're like,
why do I keep picking this guy?
Or what exactly is it that I'm saying to the opposite sex that is causing this
behavior?
Speaking from experience.
You know,
I remember when I got to my mid thirties and I was like,
dude,
chicks of fucking,
oh,
they're all fucking psychos.
You know,
and by then I was just like,
wait a minute,
but what are you doing?
What are you doing?
You know?
It actually turned around and I looked at myself and I said,
oh,
this is what I'm doing.
You know?
And then I,
I decided to stop,
you know,
fishing in the same area,
pulling out the same God damn fish.
Right?
I blamed the victim
and all of that.
It's all you women out there who you know,
shaking the plaster Rati your hair,
you know,
every once in a while,
every once in a while it might be you.
I'm just saying like just say one out of 3 million times when someone punches a
wall near your head,
maybe you shouldn't bring up things about his family or whatever the fuck it is
that said,
uh,
blows other times,
you know,
the guys who are aggressive and they shouldn't do that.
And um,
you know,
maybe they wouldn't be so many home depots out there if there weren't so many
guys with misdirected anger,
punching holes right next to their girlfriends heads
are Kelly,
could you just shut up for a second with your pedophilia?
This woman here has some plaster in our hair and she would like to,
uh,
tell her story.
Wireless is going down if you don't mind.
Um,
alright,
plowing ahead here.
So,
uh,
oh,
you know what,
I got into the premier league a little bit,
cause I know Liverpool was up by one point.
And from what I heard,
by the time we get to Manchester,
man city was up by one point.
So
let's see.
Premiere league standings.
Oh,
and everybody's trying to explain offsides to me.
All they can say is the reason why they have offsides is so people won't hang
down at the other end of the net.
And other end of the pitch,
it's like,
well,
why don't you just have a blue line like hockey?
All right.
And then nobody can hang down by the other goal and then on,
and then if somebody bringing it down the fucking field and they're faster,
then the defensive line,
they get past.
I mean,
you have what's known in hockey as a break away.
The crowd gets on its feet and there's exciting shows.
Hey Scott,
Jesus fucking Christ,
he scored,
don't understand it.
I understand the not hanging thing.
Oh Man.
City up by one fucking point.
Okay.
All right.
And I,
I realized that somebody told me I was wrong.
That,
uh,
they don't have Saudi Arabian money behind them.
Uh,
they have,
uh,
Abu Dhabi,
Baba boy,
they have that money behind him.
All right.
What's going on?
What's,
who's,
who's playing less?
Just city is playing.
Who gives a fleas are a bunch of fucking teams that aren't in it anymore.
I don't care about any of these fucking teams.
When his Liverpool or man city play a next,
that's,
that's the two you got to get into all you fucking yanks,
fellow yanks.
Listen to this shit slide in.
Now,
at the end of the goddamn season,
um,
there's like 10 games left.
So,
you know,
if you watch all 10 Liverpool Games,
you probably see about nine goals.
So buckle up for that excitement.
Offsides uh,
no,
it's not that bad.
I'm kidding.
All right.
Um,
what am I up to here?
By the way,
fucking jet lag to shit.
I had a great flight back.
I started to watch black Klansman and uh,
before the jetlag got to me and I really enjoyed that movie.
MMM.
Adam driver in a,
I don't know the names of the people in the fuck.
I'm not go with the names.
Um,
but I liked what everybody was doing in that movie.
I liked the guy playing David Duke.
Um,
can I see anything else then I watch anything else?
I don't think I did.
Oh,
you know what I watched?
I was really disappointed.
I Some I went on kids' TV.
Um,
I clicked that by accident and I,
you know,
they had all the dumb fucking kid movies,
but then they had like three episodes of the Jetsons,
which was just the Flintstones,
which was just the honeymooners.
Alright.
So they had the Jetsons.
You don't meet George Jetson.
Bada Debbie eat at the bar at the Buddha,
the Buddha Bahram [inaudible] his,
his boy l ry.
Then it's daughter Judy and they played it.
Why?
Why,
why,
why horn?
Like she's already blowing somebody.
Then Jane,
his wife,
Baba Baba Baba,
you know,
he goes to hand her money and she grabs the whole wallet,
goes to the shopping center,
Duh,
Duh.
Ooh,
being bone.
Boom.
Bump up.
Right.
I watched it.
That fucking show sucked.
Okay.
We use the episode.
I saw,
it's like they weren't even try,
just kind of went further and further down here.
The honeymoon is,
was at like the highest level of funny.
And then the Flintstones,
they got halfway up the hill and then if fucking Jetsons didn't even get out of
it was so bad.
I didn't even watch the other ones.
It's like I used to watch this shit,
but what I will say about the Jetsons is how much shit they got right about the
future.
They had video phones,
they had flat screen TVs,
they had robots in the fucking house talking to people.
Right.
The only thing they got wrong was the,
uh,
the workweek.
They thought with all the technology we were going to be working less.
And that was one of George Jetson's famous comedy lines,
big,
Oh God,
these,
these three day work weeks or murder,
you know,
flying cars.
They got that wrong.
That hasn't happened yet.
But uh,
most of the technology is a,
is right out.
It's right up there,
you know,
and in the future,
women are still spending their guys money.
Like,
you know,
like there's no tomorrow.
I mean,
some things never change.
Um,
all right.
So anyways,
the big thing is tomorrow I got to go to the gym.
I got to get back into the fucking gym because right now there's this big
temptation where it's okay,
the big two things that I was shooting.
All right,
my acting Gig at,
uh,
one day at a time or as the world turns,
General Hospital,
whatever the fuck I did,
one of those soap operas that's over.
And then I did my standup special and that's over.
And I have no TV,
no television,
no nothing coming up.
This is one of these times we put on like 10 pounds,
right?
He'd go down to the local fucking bar,
you get yourself some wings,
you have a couple of fucking beers it.
Oh.
And you look at the bears like,
wow,
that thing looks lonely.
How about a couple of little short next to it,
right?
And next thing you know,
you're a fat fuck going.
Why did I do that?
So,
mmm.
As I told you,
I'm not drinking this year,
taking the fucking year up and a,
I'm getting the booze out of my house except for the pappies and uh,
I'm just not going to have it in my house anymore.
And then basically for the rest of my life,
if I want to go out fucking drinking,
I will,
I'll go out and do it.
But just the amount of nights that when I come home,
the fact that I won't have it in my house,
it's perfect.
I've kind of,
that I figured out that's the kind of booze hound I am.
It's like boost to me is like a half a gallon of ice cream in the freezer.
If it's there,
I'm going to fucking eat it.
Right.
The booze is there.
I'm going to fucking drink it and uh,
and I like it and fucked up so I can't have it around.
That's basically it.
Oh,
just literally talking about it makes me want to do it now.
You know,
come on bill,
your did.
Um,
no,
I can't do that.
It's fucking stupid.
All right.
Not Living for myself anymore.
That's what you learn,
right?
That's what the fuck.
That's what you learn when you have a kid.
If you're doing it the right way,
you're not living for yourself anymore.
Stupid.
All right.
Put down the doughnuts.
Get rid of the cigars.
Yeah.
You don't know.
I understand.
You know like when you look at your parents are like,
why are they so goddamn boring?
Why do they just pick this regular fucking car?
Why didn't they get a cool car?
Why didn't they do any of this fucking shit?
And it's like,
oh,
because they were awesome.
Selfless fucking people.
That's why.
Okay.
And they made money and they wanted to have some leftover to,
to fucking give you when they died as opposed to going out and buying a bunch of
Nice Shit for themselves.
Somewhere along the line.
I think that was lost in today's America.
It really is like,
just the level,
the level of fashion that is fucking out there now
is insane.
They used,
I mean they used to be,
it was like fucking Andy Warhol and all the skinny doses that hung around with
them more into fashion.
And a couple of movie stars and whatever and that was fucking it.
You know,
housewives,
they were into fashion.
But Jesus Christ,
I mean if they got something that Mrs Roper was wearing,
they,
you know,
once every three years they were happy.
It wasn't this fucking shit show.
You know,
nowadays with like Instagram and fucking all of these social media just
bombarding
like
everybody guys too now
like the level with which that men give a fuck about what they look like in the
shit that they're wearing.
It's like they've put co we become like women.
I Dunno.
People with fucking sneaker collections.
When I was growing up,
you had,
you had a pair of sneakers.
That was it.
Like everybody had one pair of fucking sneakers.
I don't give a shit what sport you are playing.
Yeah.
Devastate you put on your chuck Taylors and you went out and you played it.
These are my cross trainers.
What are we playing?
I have to go inside and get my soccer shoes.
Like that shit did not fucking exist.
And you know,
you fucking know good and God damn well,
a lot of it is bullshit other than like running,
I don't know,
maybe they just got better at it.
I have no fucking idea.
You know,
all these different kinds of genes,
all these different cuts.
There was basically when I was growing up,
there was Levi's and whatever,
people who couldn't afford Levi's war,
which was wrangler,
it was tough skins.
Okay.
And then I remember the gap.
The gap had jeans for awhile.
Um,
but like the top of the line was fucking Levi's.
Oh Lee.
It was Levi's Lee Wrangler Toughskins and ember gap.
That was basically it.
That made fucking cheap jeans and corduroys and that was it.
You got two,
three fucking pairs and you were good.
You're warm until you had fucking,
until you,
you,
you made the holes in them and then that was it.
And then eventually you fucking passed them on your mother put patches on them
and pass them down to the next fucking kid.
That was it.
I look at some of the fucking childhood photos of me and the way the kids
address,
we looked like we should have been hanging out with Tom Sawyer and huck Finn.
People would like patches on the elbows of,
of,
of their shirts and all of this shit.
And it wasn't like people were broke back then.
They just,
I dunno,
there was no Amazon there.
Like when I go down to the fucking store,
driving all the way out to the Goddamn moth,
gimme a patch,
I'll just iron the sauna,
right?
Get outside fucking animal.
And that's the way it was done in 1970 [inaudible] where,
um,
all right,
I'm totally,
I don't know what's going on in football,
not football,
sorry.
And uh,
it basketball or hockey,
but I aims to sit down tonight and watch myself a couple of games so I can get
reacclimated into the greatest country that ever were that ever was that ever
will be the United States of America
and all you haters out there around the world,
you know,
with your fucking cultures and your music and your way of dressing and you funny
facial hair.
You guys can all fucking ate a dick.
All right.
You're just mad because he ain't got up my blue jeans,
my fishing pole,
my fucking four wheeler and that Bass I caught 20 minutes ago.
Uh,
all right,
butcher box,
everybody.
This much month butcher box is offering finely ground beef that's clean and
delicious and is taken from the most flavorful sections of the animal.
The beef consists of trimmings from the sirloin and chuck,
which makes it so versatile.
It cooks so it cooks fast,
so it's perfect for quick weeknight dinners right now.
New members,
we'll get two pounds of this delicious ground beef for free and every box for
the life of your subscription.
What
this was,
butcher box is most popular offer last year and they're bringing it back for a
limited time only.
Wait,
you get two pounds of ground beef for free in every box for the life of your
subscription.
Wow.
Cook with peace.
The peace of mind knowing you're eating healthy,
high quality meat.
Each box comes with at least eight to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24 individual sized meals.
Unless you're a tub of shit or glutinous or have some eating disorder and you're
going to just fucking blow through all of it.
But you know,
if you got your shit together when it comes to food,
I'm not saying you're not punching the wall next to your girlfriends had.
All right.
Uh,
you can choose from five different box types.
All beef,
beef and chicken,
beef and pork mixed box.
Custom box lets you choose your own cut.
Uh,
my favorite cut of meal is there.
Their heritage breed pork is the greatest thing I've ever had for $20 off your
first box and two pounds of free grampy and every box for the life of your
subscription.
Go to butcher box.com/burr or enter the Promo Code [inaudible] B u double r.
That's butcher box.com/burr or rain or the Promo Code Burp.
Praise Jesus.
All right.
Uh,
simply safe.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
I get it.
Enough fucking reason this week
for reads and am I good?
Deep breath.
Here we go.
Simply safe.
Here's something interesting study.
Show that security systems deter burglars.
It's a fact.
It's an asterick right next to its effect.
And I can't see where I read the footnote.
Um,
but there's still a burglary every eight seconds in America.
How well,
think about it.
I don't want to think about it to explain it to me in the coffee.
I didn't come here to think,
came here to listen and buy shit.
All right,
well think about it.
Do Burglars give up just because some houses have security systems?
You know what?
I don't know.
I haven't really,
I can't remember last time I talked to somebody who openly admitted that there
were a burglar.
Well,
fortunately they did the research.
Of course not.
They just find a house that isn't protected.
That's why securing your home is truly a necessity.
So let me recommend this brilliant security system built by my friends.
Evidently at simply safe.
Simply save beliefs.
Fear has no place in a place like home.
So they made their system ridiculously smart.
Simply save sensors will protect every point of access to your home doors,
windows,
garage,
you name it.
Um,
if a burglar even tries to break in and ear shattering siren,
we'll let them know
the police are already on their way.
Best of all simply saves.
24,
seven monitoring is just 1499 a month and they'll never lock you in a longterm
contract.
More than 3 million people already know.
It feels good to fear less with simply safe.
So go with the only home security,
uh,
that you can trust.
Simply safe by going to simply save bird.com.
Go today and get free shipping and a 60 day money back guaranteed.
That's simply save bird dot con comm for the home security you can trust simply
safe bird.com.
All right,
Robin Hood,
everybody.
Oh,
the old green cut.
They're robbing the rich given to the poor.
He just wants to bang your wife.
All right,
Robin Hood.
Is it an investment?
Is is an investing app that lets you buy and sell stocks,
ETFs,
options in Cryptos all commission free.
They strive to make financial services work for everyone.
Not just the wealthy non-intimidating way for the Stock Market for stock market
newcomers to invest for the first time with true confidence.
Simply simple and intuitive.
Clear design would data presented in an easy to digest way.
Other brokerages charge up to $10 for every trade,
but Robin Hood doesn't charge commission fees,
trade stocks and keep all your profits.
Design slash ease of use.
Easy to understand charts and market data plus a trade in.
Yeah,
just four taps.
Okay.
Plus a trade and just four taps on your smartphone.
Robin Hood Web Platform also lets you view stock collections.
100 most popular sectors like entertainment and social media and curated
categories like female CEOs.
Why would you pick a company just because of that?
This,
this world has gone crazy.
How about a fucking eh CEO's who know what they're doing?
Who happened to be females?
Can you start that way?
Jesus Christ anyways,
and analyst's ratings of buy slash hold slash sell for every stock.
Learn how to invest as you build your portfolio.
Discover new stocks and track favorite companies with personalized news feeds,
custom notifications for price movements so you never miss the right movement.
The moment to invest.
Robinhood is giving listeners a free stock like apple,
Ford,
or sprint.
To help build your portfolio.
Sign up@billbirddotrobinhood.com.
That's bill burr dot Robin,
hood.com.
Oh,
here we go.
And lastly,
but not leastly.
Bateau doot,
doot,
[inaudible] me undies.
Pick and a CE.
Oh Dude,
dude,
dude.
Beyond ease me undies.
She's got a Twat.
Here we go.
Sticker at the head.
Who gives a fuck?
She's got some tits.
Were being progressive.
What happened to our next quarter profits?
We should have done
a background shirt,
shirt,
a background background check.
She really fucking sucks.
Alright,
me undies.
Ask yourself this one very important question.
Um,
is your underwear making you happy at this very moment?
Mine isn't.
It's not making me sad either.
It's just sort of fucking,
that wasn't really thinking about it.
Now I'm in my head,
right anyways.
Or are we not thinking about your underwear?
I was not beyond days.
Okay.
This is getting exciting.
It's like,
it's like I read my thoughts.
Wouldn't you like to be wearing underwear that is so soft that you can feel like
you're making love to an actual cloud all day long?
Well,
what can I just be laying on the cloud?
Do I have to be fucking it?
Uh,
well,
I've got one word for you.
Me undies.
Buzzfeed said this about me undies.
They feel like actual heaven against your skin.
What would the fuck is buzzfeed?
And when did they go to heaven?
Uh,
we're going to do assume heaven is really soft in this context.
As men said,
they feel like silk drenched in hand.
Lotion.
These undies are so soft.
They make Bob Ross's voice.
Sound like Gilbert Godfrey.
Gilbert Godfrey taken a little fucking smack there.
They're so soft.
They think that Kenny g thinks about them to get inspired to write his next
songs.
Okay?
Oh,
I thought you would say this.
So soft.
They think Kenny g needs to be stopped with his devil music.
Uh,
me undies used the coveted micro modal modal fabric,
which is a full three times softer than cotton.
Take that big cotton.
You're puffy content.
Not only will you feel your loins are being hugged by joy itself,
but me undies gives you multiple style options for both men and women.
Choose between classic colors too adventurous prince,
prince like significant others,
plant babies and shamrocks Mondays as a great offer for my listeners,
for any first time purchase when you purchasers,
when you go to Mondays,
you get 50% off and free shipping.
That's a no brainer.
Get 15% off a off a pair of the most comfortable undies you will ever put on to
get your 15% off your first pair,
free shipping and 100% satisfaction.
Fucking guaranteed.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com slash
burr.
All right,
so when you're jet lagged and you're over there in Europe,
um,
what ends up happening is just shit starts popping into your head.
MMM.
And I dunno what,
then you look it up and you're like,
my God,
I haven't thought about this in years.
And,
uh,
one of the things that popped in my head,
don't ask me why was that song by Doctor Hook sharing the night together?
Oh my God.
Yeah.
This is one of the great fucking easy listening fucking songs of all time and it
gets a bad rap.
You have to understand this is post Vietnam war post JFK getting assassinated
posts.
Bobby Kennedy posts.
Fucking the bad acid at fucking Woodstock post all of that shit.
the 60s was a rough one.
You know,
people just wanted to listen to shit and not have to fucking think.
All right,
which brought you music like this doctor Hook,
sharing the night together.
You got to listen to,
I'll post the video.
Uh,
but here are the lyrics.
You look and kind of lonely girl.
Would you lock someone new to talk to?
I yeah,
are Rad.
I swear to God,
he says that I'm feeling Canada lonely too.
And if you don't mind,
can I sit right down here besides you?
Ah,
Yay.
Rad.
I swear to God,
this sounds like,
um,
if this sounds like I'm making fun of a song,
but this is how it goes.
Um,
so then it says,
you know,
if I seem to come on too strong,
I hope that you will understand.
I say these things because I'd like to know if you're as lonely as I am and if
you'd mind Sharon the night together,
we'll Hoho yeah.
Share and the Nad together.
Whoa,
whoa.
Yeah.
Right.
Sharing the night together and later on he said we can bring in the morning girl
if you want to go that far.
And if tomorrow finds us together right here the way we are,
would you mind basically,
hey,
you know,
I'll,
we can fuck if you want or I can just stand here and talk to you for the rest of
the time.
Look it up,
Doctor Hook Sharon the na had together.
Woo Hoo.
Yeah.
Which then of course led me to doctor Hook,
sexy eyes.
I was torturing Nia with this Sharon the night,
but then she actually,
she likes sexy eyes.
Um,
I don't know why I'm talking about this shit.
Oh,
how much time have I done?
Have I have,
I haven't done my contractually obligated.
30 minutes here.
Have I spent my 30 minutes with you guys?
Um,
all right.
So what did we learn on this little podcast thing here?
Um,
don't punch a hole in the wall next to your girlfriend's head because if you do,
she'll bring that story up while we're trying to catch a pedophile.
That's something that should be,
it's entirely own fucking,
you know.
Okay.
You know what it is.
I think,
I think guys need to start having,
you know,
you're not not that,
not that we don't bitch and we fucking listen to me.
Jesus Christ.
I'd pitch it twice as much as any woman does,
but it's not organized.
We need organized complaining like,
you know,
just to balance this out.
So the next time you know,
you see a woman doing something in a middle of a fucking important story,
you can insert your agenda into it.
And then if somebody comments on it in the wrong way,
there's then a big fucking fall out and then some woman loses her.
Yeah.
Job.
You got to fight fire with fire here.
What'd you like to dance with me and hold me?
You know,
I want to be holding you.
Ah,
yeah.
Oh right.
You guys don't,
am I allowed to play just like a second of that.
I'll play just a second of it.
Let's see what happens.
The worst thing I do is I is,
I put money in doctor hooks.
Fucking hands.
I don't give a shit.
I like these guys.
All right.
Okay.
This is the oldest song is there's like no advertising before it
all your thoughts disappear.
Some more new.
It's my favorite thing ever.
Ah Yeah.
Oh Rad.
Try that tonight fellas.
There's your opening line.
Just walk up to a woman and starts singing to it.
Sing that fucking song.
Like when Tom Cruise sang that fucking song and top gun,
right.
Just walk up to some woman,
some poor fucker woman just trying to enjoy your God damn day.
Right?
So he probably just,
you know,
punch some fucking wall near right.
And she's just going out there,
right?
She cut his dick off or something.
Whatever the fuck she did.
She's just sitting there.
It's probably still in her purse.
She's trying to enjoy the drink and just come up to her,
tap her on the shoulder and just be like,
your looking kind of lonely girl.
Would you laksa want to talk to when she,
right is she gives you the look like what the fuck you get to be like.
Ah,
yeah.
Ah Right.
We can fucking go home and fuck.
Oh,
we could just stand here.
We talked for a while.
Ah,
yeah.
Right.
That was the seventies bed.
You just parted your hair down the middle and you feathered it.
You grew a fucking beard.
That was it.
You just came up with your pubes hanging out every which way when you just
fucking said Shit.
As long as you tagged it with [inaudible].
Ah,
yeah.
Right.
I guess you were in.
All right.
That's the podcast.
Everybody,
um,
thank you to everyone who came out to the tour over the last year or so,
and thank you to everyone who came out.
I feel unbelievable about what we taped and um,
I think it might be my best one.
That's what it feels like.
And uh,
I still can't believe that I got to perform at Royal Albert Hall.
It was crazy.
And the fact that I now have documented it in a special that's going to be
coming out on Netflix,
maybe the summertime,
I don't fucking know.
I am so excited about that.
I can't even begin to tell you.
And the fact that I went to,
like,
I added Liverpool this time,
I had a great time.
So the next time I come out to the UK,
Ireland and all that shit,
right,
I'm going to do that,
run through Ireland,
go up to Northern Ireland and then go right down through Scotland and just,
just do a bunch of fucking cities and uh,
and end up in London again.
And I got to tell you something.
I don't know what happened this trip.
I've always been a Paris guide.
Some point,
I don't know.
I'm starting to become a London guy.
I don't know what happened.
I'll tell you right now.
It's certainly not the fucking food,
but just the vibe of that city.
I really like,
I was still always love Paris,
you know?
But,
uh,
I don't know.
The last couple times I went there,
plus I gotta get back there.
I've never been to Wimbledon.
That's the last tennis major I need to see life seen.
A couple of US opens to French's in one fucking Australian and I've never been
to the,
the greatest one,
the one on the grass to grass fucking court practice at Wimbledon with Dick
Enberg rest his soul.
When I was growing up and I used to watch Bjorn Borg verse John Mcenroe and then
Mac was the guy and then a uh,
what's his face came through there?
Boris Becker,
right?
The redheaded German guy.
I'm like,
oh my God,
there's another one out there.
Right.
He came in 17 years old,
one in fucking 85.
You know,
von Lender was always there looking like a fucking giant.
Uh,
I know he always looked more like a rockstar to me.
Like that guy.
Oh saying that,
talk about pop music,
pop music man,
that Guy London salt,
they had,
fuck,
it's opt in.
Everybody talking about pop music,
you look and he was new wave.
He looked like a new wave singer to me,
and then it was going east east and he featured bitch or whatever it was.
That other guy,
Jim Courier,
who kind of looked like Phil Sims,
his younger brother.
I can't believe I remember all these guys,
right?
And right as I was getting used to all of them,
then all of a sudden came fucking,
uh,
what's his face from Vegas rule?
One of the best books I ever saw open ever read,
fuck is his name.
He named,
he married a Steffi Graf.
He had to shave his head,
like make,
and now he just has a beer Jay way.
I went,
the fuck's his name.
The fuck is his name.
I saw him play
whatever.
And then fucking a peach.
Sanford's then I started doing comedy right around then what the fuck is that
guy's name?
He stole the fucking commercials about being a rebel.
This is going to torture me
second.
I,
I did.
You can't,
I can't.
This,
these,
one of the only fucking people that went on all four surfaces.
I gotta look it up and there's no fucking way I'm closing this fucking podcast.
Not knowing who that guy's name is.
Tennis Book.
Open.
Boom.
What do you mean I'm not connected to the Internet?
I'm always connected to the Internet.
God dammit.
Come on.
He didn't even want to fucking play.
Oh fuck you open.
And our Andre August seat.
Jesus Christ.
Bill.
Call yourself a sports fan.
Andre Agassi.
That's right.
And then I don't know where it went.
Then the next guy who came along there was that guy who he looked like a,
the guy from dude,
where's my car?
Who did punked and married Demi Moore.
Ashton Kutcher.
It was a tennis player that looked like him.
And then there was the,
the the Croatian dude who just,
we just won the French,
the knee.
I can't fucking remember.
I don't,
I don't pretend to understand shit.
All right.
You know,
I could've just ended on how psyched I was about my special rather than fucking
talking about tennis.
But you know,
isn't that the charm of this podcast?
All right,
I hope I got you through your workout or whatever.
The fuck it is you did,
are you a little plane ride or ride home?
Huh?
You almost home.
Do you want me to keep talking?
Oh my God.
Can we be like podcast best days and you just fucking talk to,
you know what?
Fuck you.
I got shit to do.
I got shit to do today.
All right,
so I'm going to sign off now.
You know what,
you know,
here's,
here's the thing,
the,
uh,
Andrew's going to play a little bit of fucking music here and then after the
music is going to be a half hour greatest hits from a Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast from a Thursday,
I don't know,
a year ago,
four years ago.
I don't even know how long I've been doing these.
And uh,
that'll fill up your hour.
All right?
So that's it.
Okay.
God bless all yet.
Have a great weekend and I'll see you [inaudible]
[inaudible]
share with them.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's [inaudible] and it's the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
March 7th,
2011 there.
I set it right.
2011,
2011.
Um,
I'm down here in Miami,
Miami beach.
I did the,
uh,
south beach comedy festival,
this,
uh,
this past Friday night.
And uh,
the fuck did I do,
I worked at the new symphony theater and uh,
it was funny.
I worked there Friday night and Thursday night,
the first comedian ever to perform there cause it's basically designed for a
symphony was a Kathleen Madigan.
So they had an all redhead weekend,
which I thought was nice,
you know,
for once they paid attention to one of the,
a overlooked minorities out there,
you know,
how come we don't get a day on the calendar?
What about us?
Persecuted by the Sun.
Do you know what it's like to be persecuted from Sunup to sundown?
I don't think you do all you fucking bitch and people from other God damn
fucking groups.
I've had it.
Uh,
anyways,
yeah,
down here on Miami beach and everyone is dressed like a hooker.
You know,
this is really just a,
it's a bunch of,
I dunno,
really good looking women who are dressed as fucking trashy as you possibly can.
None of them do you look at like,
God,
I could marry that girl.
You just look at all of them and you just start thinking about porno.
Um,
I don't get it.
It's that,
and I can't just say that it's c a Miami beach area cause I've kind of seen that
in like a number of different cities.
It's that,
that Kim Kardashians,
Paris Hilton influence where,
I dunno,
I don't know what happened to broads,
I don't know how they went from the 1950s to early sixties which I think was the
high point of Cla.
At least classy looking women.
God knows there was plenty of gold digging horseback then.
But that whole era there,
man,
the way they dressed telling you they look classy,
your approach to them was different.
Down here it's just,
it's fucking ridiculous.
I'm sitting there with my lady,
I'm trying to pay attention to her as she's talking to me and these two checks
at the fucking next table.
Just go sit in there with a tits still.
Like they're almost,
they were as close to being out of her dress as humanly fucking possible,
you know?
So that's what am I thinking?
Am I looking at her like,
oh,
look at that beautiful,
beautiful woman.
I'm not,
I'm thinking,
what would it be like if I just stuck my Dick Right in the cleavage as my end of
my girl's voice just fades off in the background.
Hey Tammy.
Hey Man.
Maybe you married.
Get a jet ski.
I can't fucking hear what she's saying.
Um,
yeah,
it's,
uh,
I've had it.
I've had enough down here.
I am.
I'm fucking done with it.
I'm going in the ocean.
I respect the ocean.
All right.
There's sharks in there is Barracuda.
There's jellyfish.
That goddamn ocean itself can just get mad at you and drag you out to fucking
see when it feels like it.
And then you're supposed to remain calm and just sort of,
oh,
which way is it dragging me?
I guess I'll swim sideways.
I think that's what I'll do.
You know?
Does the ocean just fucking attack?
She pulls your bathing suit off,
you know,
if you survive,
you going to be walking up there with the sun burned Dick.
Is that what you want?
I just know what I want.
It's not what I'm looking for in a vacation.
All right.
Okay.
These fucking ladies down here,
they're ridiculous.
And I've been making fun of him all week and uh,
every brought have been around.
Uh,
yeah.
I don't know that they are,
or people from Miami,
they try to defend them.
Uh,
you do,
you die.
He doesn't understand and hits Miami.
The weather.
It's just,
we are used to walking around with,
let's shut the fuck up.
Walking around less clothes.
All right.
EMEA,
tits,
hanging out of your fucking shirt and having a shirt design to show as much of
your teddy as humanly fucking possible at.
That's a different thing.
All right?
That's not all my God,
it's so fucking hot out.
You know,
I saw it.
Right.
You know,
it was funny.
It was late at night and one of these,
these hooker dressed women who wasn't a hooker,
was walking by herself on the other side of the street.
And I said to the guy,
go look at that.
Right there I go.
That's your daughter that you daughter walking down the street.
What are you gonna say to her?
And he just started laughing,
shaking his head.
It's like,
exactly.
She looks like a fucking streetwalker and now she's away from the God heard.
Well,
what are you gonna say to her
fucking five inch fucking he every God damn one of them.
How much,
how much for a fucking blow job?
Um,
yeah,
that,
that really is Miami beach.
So if you want to come down,
if you want to come down here and you want to bang a 10,
uh,
I think it's almost impossible not to because if you hook up with anything down
here,
they're absolutely fucking gorgeous.
And they're dressed like absolute fucking hookers.
Um,
yeah,
I think I saw maybe two or three class acts the entire time I was down here.
So,
um,
it was going to be great as the amount of people who are going to fucking email
me and they're going to try to defend,
um,
what is going on down here.
All right.
And all you females from Miami who going to defend this type of shit?
Let me ask you this.
If you save her,
if you savor not,
you saved your fucking savior.
Jesus h Christ showed up,
okay?
And he was at one of those after parties,
all of a sudden,
you know,
he finally comes back,
improves assholes like me,
wrong.
There he is.
Jay Star,
you know on the one and two with the fucking headset on,
right up there.
Fucking all of a sudden starts re remix in key bear and mom and dad.
You're
Christ has died for rose,
okay.
And has risen from the dead.
Jesus.
Um,
all right.
And he comes back.
I be aren't you?
At the very least a second.
You see you,
I know two things.
You're going to do.
One,
you going to take off those God damn shoes.
And number two,
you're going to reach for you a little granny shawl to cover your tits up.
That's what you're going gonna do.
I think that's what you're gonna do.
And you're probably going to try and stand behind as many thick legged,
sturdy horse as you possibly can as you text your friend o m.
G can you please find me a pair of pants?
Okay.
What would Jesus do?
Everybody.
What would he do?
I'm probably going to get a ton of shit for trash and fucking Miami like dead
like I did from the potheads last week.
Some guy actually gave me shit cause I do that,
that voice.
Hey me.
And he's like,
I've never heard anyone shut.
Even though what I'm talking about.
Go Watch that documentary on the Fillmore.
All right.
It's a fucking,
it's an impression of the hippies from Woodstock.
I realized that people don't talk like that anymore.
I'm exaggerating for comedic effect.
You fucking cunt.
I felt when you smoked weed,
everything became funny.
Why aren't you giggling right now?
Ah,
angry pothead.
And you never answered my fucking question.
None of you did.
How many weed smokers?
All right,
who fucking,
I came on with my five.
My fucking question about mushrooms.
It's trying to make some sort of point.
Last week you guys were all afraid of it stayed away.
You changed the subject like a bunch of fucking politicians.
When's the economy going to turn around?
Governor,
you know,
I'm not teach 70 till this tub was built.
We Out of vision.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Answer the Goddamn question.
Um,
anyways,
so I got to see all sides of this state.
I saw the who was,
I saw the,
uh,
you know,
the fist pumpers,
that really sounds fucking filthy,
doesn't it?
A little bunch of twinkle toes down here too.
And then after I took a tour of the everglades the next day,
right?
Finally got to do that.
Went on a fan boat.
It,
uh,
I gotta admit,
man,
I was pretty fucking nervous.
Okay.
First of all,
you know what's great is you,
you go outside of Miami and you get a half a mile out there and the drop off.
It's just like the ocean,
you know,
we just sort of weighed out and everything's great.
And what are,
what do you call one of those drop offs?
We have any oceanography,
oceanographers listening,
what do you call that?
Where all of a sudden it goes from like,
you know,
five feet deep to like 125 feet and you just slip into that darker water and no
one ever hears from you again,
you know?
And then one day you come crawling back up on the fucking beach.
Yeah.
With three quarters of your body going like,
like the end of the terminator.
The first one,
you know when he crawls out after he sticks that little canister and his robot
rib cage.
You remember that nick just starts crawling.
I actually watched that movie unedited.
Fucking great film stands up.
Stands the test of time.
Um,
anyways,
what the fuck am I talking about?
Yeah.
So I started the second you get outside the dropoff where it goes from almond,
Miami Bitch.
And um,
for some reason still wearing those white louvered Kanye West Grammy glasses
that he wore like five years ago.
Um,
okay.
Yeah.
What's funny about him?
He broke his jaw.
Now he always looks upset.
He's got that bulldog mouth with his is his bottom lip sticks out a little,
little more than the upper lip.
Um,
anyways,
so you go out there and it just immediately becomes,
you want your shale.
Some frog legs.
Got Myself pickup truck.
It's the one out there with the steel balls hanging off of it.
Hey,
like my mullet,
you're like this shit.
I'm immediately went out there and all of a sudden there's like,
there's like signs,
billboards for like Bingo Parlor and this casinos.
So we go all the way out and as we're driving they got these goddamn canals and
uh,
this,
these,
these fucking alligators
hanging out.
Not big ones.
Just sort of like little,
like a,
I don't know,
little five footers,
but still
okay.
Five foot alligator man.
If that thing bitch,
you,
uh,
you know,
I'm sure you can maybe pull yourself away from the thing.
I don't know what,
I don't know what your door are.
You one of your friends could start,
I guess you poke them in the,
I have no idea what the fuck you dude or,
but you're,
you're definitely losing your calf muscle or a chunk of your leg,
you know.
Okay.
Broken arm.
When they start doing that God damn death role,
they just lay in there.
I Dunno,
like people down here,
they used to him alligators and shit,
but like if someone like me,
a Yankee from up north,
I really don't do well with reptiles.
They've,
they,
they freak me the fuck out.
So I know I'm on my way to the everglades.
They got all these alligators.
They have a water moccasins or cotton mouth does,
they're called.
And I learned,
cause they,
they sit there with their mouths open when the,
when they feel like they're threatened and they have all,
it's all white inside their mouths.
It's like black Mambas.
I always thought that snake was black.
It isn't the inside of its mouth is black.
The outside.
He's sort of a gray now Jesus Christ built what does his fucking animal planet.
Can you get to the goddamn comedy a go fuck yourselves.
I learned some things this week,
so we show up out there,
right?
It's me and the comedian in both our fucking ladies and uh,
took one of those fan boats.
Now I'm going to give you some advice.
All right?
You can be a cheap fuck and go on one of those fucking a air boats,
I guess they call them and go on there with like 10,
12,
I the fucking people.
Or You can shell out another 20 bucks ahead and you can go on one by yourself.
I definitely suggest that one because,
uh,
this time of year,
the waters a little bit shallow and the other people will get bogged down with
the weight and there's,
and we fucking blew by all of them.
And a little disappointed.
I didn't get to see too many fucking alligators.
I guess they were mating and they're shy and they're in the fucking tall grass
or some shit.
I don't know what was going on.
So for the first three quarters of it,
all I'm seeing is a bunch of God damn birds.
All right.
Those white ones with the s the s turn fucking next.
Um,
I'm not gonna lie to here was actually,
it was amazing and I was absolutely terrified than any second one of those
fucking alligators was going to come up and stuff and just rip off one of my
legs.
And,
uh,
plus you can't believe down here the amount of misinformation on alligators.
These people were trying to tell me that those things can run 30 miles an hour.
They go,
they can't run 30 miles an hour for a long time.
And they also,
they can't,
like,
they can't run like Barry Sanders.
They could just kind of go in a straight line.
So what you do is you supposed to serpentine,
which I don't get that.
It's like,
should you just run in a straight line and then break?
Right.
Why would you then break left and become,
you'd end up back in his fucking scope,
wouldn't ya?
I don't know what.
So I finally go on the fucking Internet.
I'm like,
give me a God damn break.
Those fat fucks can run that fast.
And it turns out,
uh,
answers.com how fast can they run?
Says alligators cannot run at 35 miles per hour is previously,
as a previous answer said 35 miles an hour is how fast a horse runs or an
Olympic speed skater.
Uh,
it,
they said it's faster.
It's fast at 35 miles an hour is faster than a deer.
People tend to make outrageous claims about crocodiles with no basis.
Um,
just today I was a on an everglades tour in the guide,
the guide said they could go 35 miles an hour on land set of fast alligator Mike
go eight or nine miles per hour.
According to a study in Australia,
young crocodiles might be able to reach his fast as 10.5 miles an hour,
but only over a few yards.
And also their ambush,
they usually ambush.
People saw that,
I don't know,
they said no.
If they fucking run,
they usually just run away.
They run it back to water.
Um,
they run like fat people will,
you run and all of a sudden you lose your footing and you just do a face plant.
That's what they do.
They just try to stay up and then they do a face plant right into the fucker
water.
But once they get in the water,
you're screwed.
So I was also thinking with all these,
God damn alligator's laying around,
you know,
how many,
how many people get killed a year?
And evidently it,
it's not that many.
They only have like,
they have like four or five attacks year.
That's it.
Four or five tests a year,
but then they had like three people died all in one fucking week or three people
down here got attacked.
Some woman jog or some shit.
She was jogging and she decided to fucking cool off her feet in the water and
that was the last time they saw her.
Okay,
why the fuck would you do that?
Why would you do that?
That's why like whenever I watched like a fucking one of those horror movies
from back in the day,
that's what you're always yelling as you're watching it.
Like what?
Why are you going in there?
Why are you doing that?
Like this.
The same thing.
If you live in Florida,
if you feed a hot fucking tough it out.
Go home and stick them in the tub.
Dangle them in that fucking water.
Hugh.
Imagine that Shit.
Oh my God.
Checking you get pulled in to this to the moment you're underwater.
You have to think,
I would think.
Yeah.
Well,
however long it takes the alligator to pull you from where you're seated into
the water.
What do you think that is?
Point eight seconds.
I would say for 0.4 seconds.
The first point to you like what the fuck?
Point three your holy Shit.
Point four you have hope
maybe I can do.
Maybe I can do this.
Oh,
there's my ring.
Okay.
There it is.
Hey Dude,
I'm doing my podcast.
Let me call you right back in about an hour,
right?
Uh,
um.
Okay.
Bom,
bom.
That's the only normal one I can get.
You want to hear my fucking things?
I was in such a great moment there.
All right,
so 0.4 seconds.
You have hope.
Well,
maybe I could do.
Oh no I can't.
That's 0.5.
Then you just like,
I'm dead.
Point five to 0.8.
You're like,
I can't believe I'm going to get,
I'm going to die via alligator.
And then once you're under the water,
that's when you renew.
Renew your relationship with the Lord.
And I know what you guys are probably thinking.
You're probably thinking what bill,
because you don't believe in that shit.
What would you be thinking?
I would be praying to God and his second got a fucking hedge my bets.
My prayers will be hilarious.
If you do exist and you do give a fuck,
get me out of this or make it quick.
Okay.
Oh my God.
How long do you think it takes?
Like how long do you think before you dead?
Here's the thing,
just sitting at Chowan on your liver and you're going like,
uh,
for the love of God eat my heart's Oregon.
I so getting really fucking more of it,
but uh,
I dunno man,
I could not get comfortable.
So we ended up going out there on the everglades.
I definitely recommend it,
although if you're going to go,
um,
try to go April and may because the water levels come up I guess.
And then also the mosquitoes aren't that bad.
There's a little travel tip for you.
April or may water levels come up.
They're mating season.
Right?
I was just joking about them wanting to make the fucking tall grass and full of
shit.
Um,
gold during April and may definitely get your own fucking boat.
And,
uh,
I would also say venture out as far as you can into the everglades.
Don't stop at the first one.
Just keep going.
Go as far as you can until you're out there with some fucking a seminal Indians,
you know,
and they're calling you.
And then the guide says white man,
speak with forked tongue.
I think that that's the one you want to get on.
Um,
we actually,
we had just a couple of redneck dudes and the redneck dude we had,
the guy's name was Regis and uh,
they had all this uh,
airboat humor,
you know,
where they would just like,
do you know if you enjoy the tour,
get out to the left.
If he didn't get out to the wreck,
kick,
get it.
Cause then you'd step in the water and the alligators are in there.
But seriously,
folks,
don't hang your legs off the boat at any forums.
We,
we're going through here,
uh,
those you who are wearing hats,
I suggest you take them off or turn them off backwards.
Cause if you don't,
we,
they leave the known to fly off.
They go into the fan.
And then they don't fit as well.
Could kick,
kick,
kick off.
Just kidding.
Alright folks,
seriously turn your hatch.
Rab.
Um,
if you're wondering,
no,
I am not parked shark.
That's just my awful dentition job.
Jazz fucking with you.
Keep the fucking hands and legs inside of the boat at all times.
Uh,
this one an alligator's sounds like when it's trying to make,
they did all that shit.
It was fucking tremendous.
We saw another boat that got it.
Got um,
it was hilarious.
This boat,
one of those boats that had too many people on it.
It actually a when a ground,
so they were just sitting out in the everglades waiting to be told in.
So we came over to see if we can help him out.
And it was hilarious.
It was like six people all from Germany.
So they were getting the full on redneck experience.
I would love to hear the stories that are going to tell when they get back.
They just sitting there,
we pull up near like one tie.
Hello.
Hi.
And they had the most redneck dude ever and he was just standing there.
He completely given up like there's no way and get towed out.
And so he puts his cigarette in his mouth and he's fishing for his lighter as
he's talking to the other redneck go and he's like,
yeah,
God damn garbage.
Can you know what they say?
Well go chrome it
is he saying he's saying it like you're starting to look there.
If you know what this is,
lips together cause he wants to hold onto the cigarettes.
So cigarettes sitting there flapping around as he's reaching for his lighter and
it was amazing.
It was one of those moments as a performer,
I'm watching this guy going,
this guy doesn't even realize it,
but this guy is actually,
if someone could imitate
him,
they would win an Oscar with what he's doing right now just sitting there,
no drag.
Well go chrome but that cigarette flap and not tie it up,
boy,
fuck a rock of dark snikers honor it.
It was just so God damn authentic.
And we,
I was sitting there with Nia and we both immediately just look down at the
ground and just started cracking up.
And a not an asshole.
Why not judging them.
And I looked over at me at one point,
I was like,
you know what,
Lemmy doesn't have shit on this guy.
I'm not saying this guy's beyond Lemmy,
but these two could fucking hang out.
And they would be two peas in a pod.
Um,
speaking of which underrated anybody see that,
that documentary on Lemmy from Motorhead?
Fucking tremendous.
Um,
I'm one of those radio motor had fans.
All I know is
the ace of spades,
but uh,
definitely a fascinating guy and uh,
he and I think it's on demand this month.
Should definitely try and check it out.
So anyway,
so we ended up going through the fucking everglades and then the end,
I know I made fun of those fan boat guys,
but they're actually,
they're great dudes.
Tip Him,
don't be a fucking asshole and a then we got off and they,
uh,
they gave us a baby alligator and they said that you get one of these,
you get one of these with every trip.
Take it sticking in water.
Don't tell anybody you got it.
And,
uh,
when it gets too big,
you just flush it down the toilet.
Now they didn't,
they actually,
they just let us hold one.
And uh,
it was actually pretty cool.
I kind of,
I was terrified to do it.
Not like terrified.
I just thought it was going to fucking bite my finger off.
So,
uh,
it was weird the dog training that,
that I,
that I got through working with Cleo.
MMM.
I realized that when you,
at least when you go to make a move with a dog,
if you're going to go pet a dog,
you don't,
no pun intended alligator arms.
You don't start the Pettit and then go,
oh,
wait a minute if they're going to bite me,
because then they feel that and then that makes them feel fucked up.
MMM.
So the guy goes,
you know,
take the alligator,
grab it right here.
And before I would even think,
I just fucking made sure I had its mouth closed,
held it by it's God damn tail.
And uh,
I got the picture taken,
but I got to admit,
I was nervous handing it back.
You know,
like I think I could actually hold the most poisonous snake in the world.
If you showed me how to do it,
I think I could grab it by the back of its head,
you know,
and I wouldn't get bit,
but when I was going to get bit was the the letting go of it.
Like I don't know,
I don't get that whole,
do you like fucking throw it like hold onto the tail so it can't coil up and
then you,
you fuck.
Why am I asking you guys like your fucking snake experts?
You know what somebody is going to be,
hey,
you guys want to hear about the,
I definitely recommend that.
And tonight I'm actually going to go to the,
uh,
actually this would be tomorrow night with the podcast.
I'm going to the,
uh,
the panthers are playing the Washington capitals going to get to see,
Alex,
what is he?
The great there's,
or what they call them.
Okay.
Alexander the Great,
I'm going to get to watch him and his fucking nine goals this year.
The fuck the capital's doing.
Yeah.
You know,
can they attend?
They can.
I turn that horse loose.
What's going on with those guys?
How about them broads?
But they went 6.06 and o on their,
their uh,
their road trip one another one at home and last night they stole a point from
the penguins.
It's motherfuckers are seven oh one one the last eight games.
If you can't do the math,
that's fucking great.
I hope they're not peaking too early,
but all of a sudden that Yo,
we look all right with the penguins injuries.
I Dunno.
Who Do you think it's going to be this year?
I think you got to go with the fly.
Yes.
You know they were there last year.
They came.
Oh,
so fuck a close.
I think the flyers or the Goddamn team to beat,
but for some reason the penguins with all their injuries.
The filthy fucking Pittsburgh Penguins.
Um,
those sons of bitches.
Yeah,
they seem to be playing all right too.
I don't,
it all comes down.
Can you beat them four times since in seven games?
I don't know.
I don't fucking know.
All right.
Yeah.
You guys want to read some on?
Want me to read some,
uh,
angry email?
An angry email from a fuckin pothead.
Uh,
all right,
I got one.
Who disagrees with my view on pot?
Okay,
Bill.
Dude,
you have obviously never regularly hung out with any weed smokers or smoked weed
yourself wrong on both counts right there,
sir.
I hung out with some of the biggest potheads you're ever going to meet in your
life.
I'm talking about people who smoked every fucking day because they couldn't
deal.
Uh,
they use stuff.
They quotes like this.
Why do you get high at work?
Why do you,
why do you smoke all the time?
Dude,
I like pot because it turns my world,
turns my life into a movie.
That's what this buddy of mine said.
All right,
so yes,
I have hung out with them.
He said,
you are usually on point with what you say,
but you talk like someone who was absolutely zero knowledge of weed.
I've never seen someone with that.
I've never seen.
So this is the guy,
I never seen him.
Something with that tire,
cliched pot,
smoker voice.
Obviously you haven't,
all right,
but if you watch shaggy and Scooby,
you see it right there.
They're making fun of the whole Woodstock generation.
Um,
and did I mention that or I can't even remember if you watch that fucking,
uh,
there's a documentary about Bill Graham and there's,
and he's having the last night at the Fillmore and there's an,
there's a musician.
If anybody can find the clip on Youtube,
I think they took it down.
That guy was just like,
well,
hey man,
you know,
just like,
man,
it's like,
like fuck you and thanks for their memories,
man.
You know what I'm saying?
Man,
you got to listen to the guy.
That's the guy everybody's making fun of.
All right.
That's what I'm doing.
I realized that people in 2011 don't talk that way,
sir.
So anyways,
he said,
most pot smokers are like anyone else and don't sound like they have down
syndrome.
As funny as you are,
it pains me to hear you talk about your ass when usually you have good points.
Please smoke a joint and shut the hell.
All right.
That part was funny.
Uh,
ps,
I know you're going to tell me to go fuck myself cause it's your podcast,
but I'm sure I'm not the only one who notices this about you.
Uh,
you know what I would tell you what I'm really sick of.
I'm really sick of overly sensitive fucking pot smokers.
You know,
you guys are about to self righteous is fucking Jesus freaks.
I've had it.
I've had it with you guys.
I've had it with your lies of how,
uh,
you know,
there's like there's no they drinking and driving.
You can get pulled over for that and there's a test and there's nothing for
weed.
And then pot smokers say,
well you know what?
I actually think you drive better when you're high.
You know,
everything's so fucking clear.
They say dumb shit like that.
They say smoking weed is not addicting.
I just do it cause I like it.
You're all fucking full of shit.
All right.
I think weed is one of the more dangerous drugs is because everybody thinks it
isn't fucking dangerous.
And I think the danger of that drug is that it,
I don't know.
It just makes you want to sit on the goddamn couch.
All right,
now kind.
Of course someone's going to send me an email.
I smoke weed every fucking day and I'm a fucking the Valedictorian of my class.
Really?
Well,
you're a fucking exception.
All right.
You are doing damage to your brain.
You are fucking burning up your brain cells.
Why can't weed smoke as admit that?
Is it because it's illegal and you want to make it legal that you can't be
honest the way a drunk like I am,
that alcohol fucking turns your nose into fucking,
you look like WC fields.
It fucks up your liver.
It kills brain cells.
You get behind the wheel of a car and you could kill yourself or even worse,
kill somebody else.
Why can't you guys admit that ship?
Ha Ha man.
Why can't you say that man?
I'm just fucking with you by the way.
You know what?
I can't.
I can't actually,
you can't say I'll,
I'll weed smokers like that cause I only got one fucking email.
Somebody really disagreeing with me on my views on weed.
Um,
okay.
I Dunno.
I don't fucking know.
You know my one thing I will,
I will,
I will stand by this cause I am just fucking around.
I do know this.
All right.
You can come home after work and have a beer,
possibly two beers,
depending on your tolerance and yet maybe you're a little buzzed.
That's it.
These mother fuckers who come home and get,
they get high.
You get high.
You basically do the same as me drinking like six beers.
It'd be like me getting drunk every night.
If I drank six beers every night,
my girl would be talking to me going,
I think you need to go to some meetings,
but there's really no meetings for people who smoke weed.
Basically every fuck if he,
if you're getting high for fucking nights a week,
think about this shit.
All right?
You multiply that times 52 fucking weeks not to freak you out,
man.
This is fucking 208 days of the year.
You're fucking high.
If I'm getting drunk,
torn eight times a year,
what's the F was I at one point I think I was,
that's what I finally,
I started doing the fucking math and I was like,
I am very quietly kind of a fucking alcoholic here.
If you,
if you get drunk two times a week,
a year,
I'm really sounded like a fucking cunt right now,
but I'm just,
this is just shit I worked out.
If you get drunk two times a week,
Friday,
Saturday night,
that's over a hundred days a year.
That's basically a third of the year your shit faced and that's only two times a
fucking week.
Eight days a month.
You don't think you throw in the random Monday night football.
I would like another Pale Ale,
you know?
Next thing you know you had three or four walk out of the house.
You fucking feel like you're floating in your loafers,
right?
You get out there and your Toyota Camry,
you didn't hit anybody.
You go home,
you wake up the next day,
you feel like shit.
Right?
How many times you do that?
A year at least 20 right?
There's a 30 year your shit faced.
So pot smokers on the other hand,
I,
you know,
they,
they got a whole different thing.
Like if I fucking walked by a guy in a car and he's got a beer,
I can't just come up to the window.
Amen.
Let me get,
let me get a couple of Poles off of that.
Just shotgun.
One of his bears.
Thanks Ben.
Thanks for getting me drunk.
Like pot smokers,
they do that shit all the time.
Maybe because it's illegal.
I don't know what it is,
but they get fucking baked,
which is the equivalent I think I have in like,
you know,
four,
five,
six beers.
What I'm saying is,
is you pot smokers,
you're a lot more fucked up than you realize.
So you get off your God damn high horses or is it,
you're not even on high horses.
You just trying to tone down the effects of that shit.
Isn't that what you're doing?
So they'll make it legal so you can just smoke it and not worry about it and not
dimension how toxic fucking weed is.
Now.
I remember when I was living in New York,
this dude came up to me,
he's like,
Yo,
I smoke this shit last night is called were tardy cause Yo,
you'd be smoking that Shit,
Yo,
you just be retarded.
You'd just be sitting there.
You'd just be sitting there like this,
Yo.
And he makes his fucking face.
Like he doesn't have a thought in his goddamn head.
All right.
All that shit.
Chronic,
all of that shit that just fucking burns your Goddam head up.
I Dunno it.
Ah,
you know,
fuck you know something.
Go fuck yourselves.
If I can sit here and admit how bad whiskey is,
and then I was sitting there like Judy Garland for a quarter of the year,
you know what I mean?
I'm not saying you should quit.
I'm not saying that you shouldn't,
did you,
you know you shouldn't smoke more of it.
I'm just saying stop acting like you're taking fucking a Flintstone vitamins,
you know?
Because if you really wanted to,
rather than smoking it,
you could turn it into a hoodie.
Okay.
All right.
The fucking declaration of independence,
isn't that what they said?
Isn't that one of the theories out there.
Declaration of independence is written on hemp paper,
man.
Um,
anyway,
so someone who agrees with my views on pot,
I can I,
the amount of listeners I'm going to fucking probably lose this week.
I'm agrees with your view on pot.
Here we go.
Hey bill this morning.
Uh,
okay.
Hey bill,
this has been bothering me for a little while now and I'm not sure what to do.
I'm 19 years old.
I go to Umass Amhurst go minutemen.
Um,
I had a,
that's one of the worst fucking names.
You know something minute men used to be like the fighters because they could be
ready in a minute,
right?
The minute man and Nicole fight the real love revolution.
And then somewhere along the line I believe hip hop and R and B turned minute
men into people who prematurely ejaculate.
Do you like how my sentence slowed down there?
Cause there was too many words with big syllables.
Uh,
not just been hitting it hard down here.
Sorry.
I had a girlfriend my first semester of college and was still in high school
when I was still in high school.
There Ya go.
Oh,
she was still in high school.
Oh wait a minute.
Sorry.
Ah,
now it's getting a little creepy.
Was she a senior?
Um,
we both knew that I would be going far away and we agreed we would stay
together.
However,
I guess her feelings changed and she wanted to be single.
I was devastated when she broke up with me and I've been really down because she
was the first girlfriend that I really liked.
Didn't I read this last week?
I think this happens to a lot of guys and I wasn't just trying to get laid.
I really liked this girl.
So after a few weeks I found out she was hooking up with this kid that I
consider to be a friend.
Okay.
This is the exact same as last week.
I swear to God.
This is different email though.
Uh,
because we've been hanging out over the summer and partying together.
What's fucked up about the whole situation is that this isn't the first,
Oh,
I read this last week,
did night.
This isn't the first time this guy has done this to me.
And at the end of my senior year,
I broke up with a different girl and this kid was hooking up with her about a
month later.
Then I answered this one.
Okay.
I let that one slide again.
I didn't really give a fuck about any of his girlfriends.
Yeah,
dude,
blah,
blah.
So it was question is,
should I go back to this kid and tell him to stop going after my ex girlfriends?
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
You should.
I mean,
who gives a fuck?
He's going after you're sloppy seconds.
Just ask them that.
I thought I said this last week.
Just call them up and be like,
listen to you.
Do you have an ability to get laid without fucking something that my Dick's
already been in?
All right.
Do I have to be your Dick Lewis and Clark?
The fuck is wrong with you.
Why don't you go forge some of your own stopped being Colby Bryan and be Michael
Jordan stopped doing the shit that I already did and taking credit for it.
You fucking cunt.
Fuck you.
And that fucking whore that you're with right now.
Okay.
Do you realize that this keeps up?
Someday I'll be able to say,
Hey,
I fucked your wife right before you fell in love with her.
She loved it.
And the Aa ash,
um,
just say some mean shit like that.
All right.
Okay.
How the fuck was that?
Agrees with me on pot.
I am an idiot.
All right.
Advice.
Yeah,
Bill,
this is my tale of woe and in the interest of preserving the flow of the story,
I'm using names.
So I started at a Lexus dealership back in August a little bit after that.
A girl,
I don't give a fuck if you,
you know something.
I don't name names,
but if you guys are going to put names in your fucking thing,
I'm not going to say last names,
but I'm just going to name the names because my reading out loud skills are so
fucking bad.
I don't,
I don't have time to add other shit here.
All right.
So anyways,
so bill,
I started working at a Lexus dealership back in August a little bit after that.
A girl named Ashley started in the Accounting Department.
She was a cutie.
Uh,
for a few weeks.
I kept getting shit from the guys in the parts department for not going after
her.
That's hilarious.
What are they all married or the older perverts a look at a man who you're not
sticking your fucking Dick in.
I go over there.
What do you will fucking fig.
Um,
so they're giving me shit for not going after,
but uh,
but I had a good reason.
She was 20 years old.
I'm 23.
So it's not overly creepy,
dude.
That's not even close to being creepy.
That's good that you have a conscious about that.
But think about that.
Someday when you're fucking 47,
she's going to be 44 and she's going to be up your ass telling you were and
where you can't wear your shoes in the house.
So why don't you bang her at the height of her fucking good.
Looks.
All right.
Get that thought right out of your head.
That's my first piece of advice.
All right,
let's continue.
Uh,
right from the start,
I knew she was going to be the kind of girl that could only communicate through
her thumps text messaging a and B to a mature to handle any actual conversation,
not to sound self righteous.
Uh,
but going after against my better judgment,
I followed my Dick's advices.
Started,
started to get something going after a few weeks of US chatting.
Every once in a while I told her,
I told her I needed a massage.
Ah,
okay.
Dude,
that's a really creepy way to try to get her in the boat,
so to speak.
I need a massage.
All right,
well we'll deal with your opening lines later on in this.
All right.
But just put a little fucking,
uh,
little,
little check next to that to that.
That's not a,
that's a creepy way to fucking enter the atmosphere there.
All right.
Um,
anyways,
like a champ.
She tried her best to obliged,
but shit kept popping up when she walked by again.
I jokingly handed her my number telling her to call me and we'll schedule that
massage.
That's just creepy.
Massage is creepy.
That's,
that's a creepy word because creeps go to massage parlors and they have people
fucking do things to them.
That is fucking creepy.
And also a lot of perverts kind of go with the massage thing.
You're young,
you're 23.
I get it.
I had game at 23 beyond zero subzero freezing temperatures.
I was horrific with women at 23.
So the fact that you're even giving a girl a number,
I right.
You're way beyond where the fuck I was.
Act.
I'm not talking down to you,
but she got to get the word massage Outta your fucking game.
It's just a creepy fucking word.
And it,
it creeps women out.
Um,
anyways,
the day after I wake up with a t that,
um,
after I gave the text message,
whatever,
I give him my number,
the day after I wake up,
I have a text message says,
hey,
it's Ashley.
I can't help it.
So he said,
so I can't help but think.
Gotcha bitch.
That's nice.
So,
ah,
so after a week of texts we get together.
She finally calls me in pretty much in fights herself over to my house.
She comes over all gussied up,
perfect outfit,
perfect makeup,
the whole fucking package.
Uh,
we watched some TV and she comes up with the idea of bringing booze into the x
situation.
Very nice.
I agree.
After a few hours of,
so she finally says,
I got to go.
She gets up to leave.
She tries to give me a high five as the goodbye.
So I come back with a more of a kiss.
Good night kind of guy.
Jesus Christ,
Dude.
All she does is laugh and start walking to her car.
I got mind fucked.
All right.
First of all,
dude,
um,
you were there for two hours and you were drinking and she's over there at some
point.
There's a moment where you got to make a move.
If you don't make a move,
then it gets weird and then they just shut down and say,
okay,
this guy is an interested.
So then she's going to leave.
Then she says,
hey,
good stuff.
Because the I five year and then all of a sudden you try to make it intimate in
the last five seconds,
you're going to be there and you come with a more of a kiss.
Good night kind of guy.
That's just creepy,
dude.
You're creeping them out.
All right,
but I get it.
All right.
I was creeping them.
I wasn't,
I wasn't even in the game to creep them out at that point and I went through my
phase where I was creeping them out.
I said dumb shit like that before too.
So don't feel embarrassed or anything.
Okay.
You're just,
you're coming with a,
you know,
it's like you're writing your first five minutes of comedy here.
You know this.
None of this shit.
This is going to be embarrassing when you get older.
All right,
here we go.
This continuous,
after another week or so,
she calls me up again and invites himself over.
Very nice.
She comes over again.
All gussied up.
We pop in waiting.
I don't even know what that is.
That's a movie.
Okay.
And she gets the booze.
A few minutes go by and she asks if I want the massage.
Very nice.
He said,
I never got on my stomach's so quickly.
She straddles me.
It tells me to take my shirt off.
I get a good 30 minutes in and I asked if I'm doing her next dude.
Your lines that it's like blunt force trauma.
You just punching this girl right between her tits with you,
with the alliance here.
Um,
anyway,
she says,
she tells me she doesn't know a swipe Telogis lay down while telling her I can't
work with shirts.
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
you can you try to finesse it a little bit?
I don't do I fives.
I'm more about the kiss.
Get your tongue out this weighty.
No,
you ain't leaving the house.
You lean it against the fucking door.
When you said that.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
I say I'm not good with shirts.
Where the hell am I?
Sheets.
So she takes his shirt off and let me guess as she took her shirt off.
You didn't say anything,
you weren't touching her or anything.
You just sat there.
So it could be as awkward as humanly possible as you heard the sound of her
taking her shirt off.
Um,
is if she's just gotten arrested for drugs or something.
Uh,
she takes his shirt off and leaves on her Bra.
Of course she does.
But uh,
that quickly gets out of the picture.
Very nice.
It's fucking guys.
Oh,
cause she's 20.
I get it.
So her mind's saying no,
but she's too embarrassed if she continues.
All right.
After a while she says she has to go.
But I told her,
um,
she could just sleep here.
She agreed.
So thinking I was going to get laid.
I went and I took a piss and got back to my room to find her fully clothed with
her fucking coat on in my bed.
I couldn't stop thinking,
what the fuck he goes.
I slept pretty good though.
All right.
For all you rookies out there,
uh,
there's a lot of guilt that young women have when they're,
when they're going to hook up or whatever that they're doing.
They got a lot of voices in their hand and by my being of heart and that type of
thing.
So the thing is you got to keep the fucking plates spinning.
All right?
You can't leave them alone if you leave him alone for any period of time.
That gives them a chance to entertain that voice that's saying,
why am I doing this?
Do I want to do this?
I work with this guy.
We're not even going out.
You gave her time to basically do the right thing.
Um,
I dunno.
So yeah,
so yeah,
of course you come back,
she's fully fucking clothes.
It's like a,
and I don't,
I don't know.
Using analogies now.
I'm all set.
I'm feeling like a creep now cause I'm trying to teach you how to fucking banged
a girl like this.
This whole fucking emails just really creepy,
but I'm halfway through it.
I can't stop now people.
All right,
let's go.
He says now for the good part,
uh,
December rolled around.
Okay,
well you've really never give.
Told me when this started.
Oh,
he said August.
That's right.
My fault.
All right.
December rolled around and there was a company Christmas party,
oh Jesus.
At my boss's house,
which we both attended,
me and a buddy,
I'm not saying his name went and she immediately finds and latches on to me
after a few hours and her friends giving her a fuck load of booze to,
to suck on.
She comes up to me and asked if I want to get out of there while biting her
lower lip and other gestures to that drive me crazy.
I agree.
Then she goes out her way to invite this,
this other dude along,
which leads us to believe that this going to be some sort of double penetration
action.
Jesus Christ.
Now she's bringing this other guy
to fuck the whole thing up.
That's going to be like the chaperone.
So anyways,
we choose do this is,
this is how,
how uh,
you know,
the next day the phone call,
this is how all this shit goes.
Cause men and women just do not think the fucking same way,
especially at this God damn age completely not understanding what's going on
here.
Anyway,
so he said,
we choose my place for the,
for the alcohol and head out while we're walking out to the car.
She has her hands all over me.
So I'm thinking this shit is going down to this girl.
Like she's a Dick Tease man.
Jesus Christ.
We get to my place and we crack open some bear and she blatantly asked me to put
some porn on to watch.
Isn't this what happened to like the fucking Duke Lacrosse team?
Um,
at this point I think it's,
it's fucking over with.
I start getting all touchy feely with her and she seems a little annoyed.
Finally she starts to wrestle with me and I go in to kiss her and she dodges me
thinking she was playing.
I continued my advances.
Now there's a lot of women getting upset here.
You can't get fucking upset when she's doing that shit.
You want to come out?
Yeah,
we just hang out a little bite of the bottom lip.
Let's put a point on.
Um,
I continue my advances and then she gets genuinely offended.
Me being a little angry.
I asked the other dude to leave.
So we can have a little chat and I proceed to ask her what the fuck PR,
what the fuck she's looking for here?
She tells me nothing and that she doesn't have any interest in me.
Fucking furious.
I just start playing a video game and drink Jamenson while she continues to ask
me what's wrong,
I'd never been so close to punching a girl.
In closing,
I started sending her incredibly asshole ish text messages.
Ah Dude,
why would you do that?
To self destruct?
Any chances of her talking to me again,
but I still left.
It still left a very conti taste in my mouth.
I'd love to hear your take on this.
All right dude.
All right.
Yeah,
she's addicted.
He's all right.
And um,
I,
I don't know if she's got it.
Fear of being alone.
She's using you,
she's using you for company.
She's probably doesn't now,
obviously it doesn't have a boyfriend,
so she needs to get rid of her little fucking sexual acts.
So she kind of takes it up to the point and then backs off from it.
But the problem is with the girl like that,
that first night she came over there,
you had the close the deal and when you didn't close the fucking deal,
that's it.
You got to fucking walk away and once you realize the girl is mind fucking you
basically being a dick tease,
you have to.
Two things you have to do.
You got to walk away and two,
you can't get mad.
You have to accept that that's part of the fucking game,
but for some reason you really want to still bang this girl.
You have to realize that.
Then what you have to do is you have to start playing mind games back with her,
which personally gets fucking exhausting.
Okay?
But if you want to do that in the future,
what you then do is the next day when you go to work,
this is provided.
You didn't get upset is when you see her,
you don't ignore her,
okay?
You're not snide door.
You're not angry to her.
What you do is you're like,
hey,
how are you doing?
A big smile if it's acceptable,
a hug at work,
if you can do that or whatever,
you just be cool with her.
All right?
But you don't try to go out with her or anything.
And then later on that day or whenever the opportunity arises,
you compliment some other female within earshot of her.
All right.
Okay.
That will cause a dick tease to be like,
wait a minute,
Wa wa Wa
fucking start coming your way.
And that's how you,
that's how you get them on the boat.
You gotta you gotta just turn what you get.
It's weird.
You got to walk backwards.
You know what it is?
It's like,
like charged magnets.
You know what I'm saying?
If you fucking,
uh,
you take a fucking,
I don't know what the fuck it is.
What am I trying to say?
I don't try to say,
it's like you take a step towards it.
If fucking goes off the other direction,
if you walk away,
it starts coming towards you and you just got to slowly,
slowly back them into the boat.
But I dunno,
I dunno.
I Dunno what to tell you as far as your fucking opening lines of what you really
have to do,
dude,
is when you just want to fuck a girl,
you have to say,
you got to present that to them,
you know?
Um,
and the only way you got,
you got to do it through bombing.
Okay.
You're,
you're,
you're blunt force trauma
period.
I,
I dunno,
it's,
it's impossible.
It's,
it's a,
it's like how do I learn how to do standup,
the right five minutes of jokes and you have to go up there.
That's all the only advice I can give you.
And you've got to go up there.
You've got to fucking figure it out for yourself.
But like,
eventually you have to just,
if you just want to bang a girl,
you can't,
uh,
does he,
you have the,
you have the right instincts.
You're steering the conversation towards sex,
but you're doing it at 90 miles an hour.
You grabbing her by the back of the head and slamming her face into the wall.
You can't do that.
Uh,
you know,
I don't know.
I don't know where,
where,
where to begin.
Yeah.
I'm trying to think of all the fucking horrific things that I did back in the
day.
Um,
I remember one time hooking up with a girl who was like 23 or 24 when I was
about 33 or 34.
Okay.
At a,
what the fuck?
She said at one point she got,
she came over to my apartment and I invite her in.
Right.
Cause I was a veteran at that point.
I don't have to take you to the movie.
Why do they come on up?
Meet me over my place.
This is embarrassing.
So she came over and one point we started fucking make it out doing whatever.
And then she says,
wait a minute,
where is this going?
She hits me with that shit.
Okay.
And I was like,
uh,
I'm like 11 years older than you.
By the time you're 30,
I'm going to be 68.
What do you mean?
Where's this going?
It's going nowhere.
Okay.
You know,
this is just basically,
yeah,
it's a sexual,
I'm basically going to be the reason why you're not going to have a midlife
crisis because all the fucked up shit you want to try but are too afraid to do
with the guy you're in love with.
You can just do it with me,
obviously.
I said a little smoother than that and then,
you know,
she was just like,
oh,
all right.
Oh Jesus Christ.
And then,
oh,
I can't even tell you what happened then.
And it's not sexual.
It's disgusting.
Yeah.
Oh God.
I gotta tell you this.
This is really fucked up.
This is why I'm so happy.
I've got a great girl now.
So we ended up fooling around
and uh,
the next morning,
wake up,
you know,
he started in the living room and it in the bedroom,
that whole thing.
You never,
you never give him a chance to reconsider.
Right.
I don't even give them the chance to fucking think about it from the living room
into the bedroom.
You don't do that.
You just constantly hands are moving and you kiss it on the whole fucking thing.
Right.
So
she goes,
this is,
I can't believe him.
I tell you this.
She goes,
I walk out into the liver gum the next day cause she's getting dressed and she's
looking for underwear.
And she had these white lace,
like foggy kind of underwear,
not a thong.
Geez.
No thought.
Yeah.
And they were in a,
they were crumpled up on the floor.
All right.
If anybody gets really grossed out,
I suggest just shut it off here right now.
All right.
I looked down at them,
so proud of myself,
you know,
that I hooked up and I looked down and there was a skid mark about,
I would say at least four inches long and those white panties.
And I was like,
what was going to fucking dry heave?
I didn't go down on her.
Thank God.
Um
Wow.
It's really just coming back.
And I was just like,
I didn't know what to do cause she was like,
yeah,
wait,
I can't find mine too.
It ha ha ha.
So I fucking went out to look for him and I found them.
And then it's just like,
you know,
if I had a stick in my apartment,
I would have picked him up and
ended up tour.
But,
uh,
I didn't have a stick,
so I acted like I couldn't find them.
I wandered over towards the kitchen and then she came walking out.
Okay.
And she's like,
oh,
there they are.
And I know she saw what the problem was and she tried to play it off and she
just put them on,
Ugh,
that I,
you know what,
let's have a vote.
Was that the most disgusting story I've ever told in the pilot?
That was fucking horrific.
Right?
I Dunno.
W was there any advice in that?
Jesus Christ,
I don't know.
How the fuck did I relived that one?
Wow.
Um,
how about some youtube videos this week?
Somebody sent me this youtube video of this guy on,
on,
uh,
Dr Phil.
He's like a,
he has this website,
men are better
than women.com.
He's really like a cartoon chauvinists cartoon character kind of chauvinist
stick person where he's just like,
you know,
women aren't good at working.
I mean they shouldn't have,
they shouldn't be allowed to vote.
Like he does shit like at that level.
Um,
which is just cartoonish.
There's a couple of funny things that he says.
At one point he's standing next to an ATM and he's taken cash out.
He goes,
this is how women perceive men.
This is how they look at us.
Which obviously not all of them do,
but it's so,
it's such a true fucking statement.
If he just adjusted a few words,
said if he said a lot of women or there's a sizable group of women that look at
guys like this,
you know,
and I know there's a lot of broads out there that are getting upset by this,
but you know,
you guys say the same shit,
don't you guys go on TV and the radio and what?
What's that expression?
A good man is hard to find.
Okay.
You know,
but for some reason you can't say a good woman's hard to find.
They are,
they are hard to find.
But this guy basically,
so he goes on,
Dr Phil and this lady,
this lady starts heckling him and I'm telling you when I say a classic classic
comeback,
this the comeback this guy has what would have,
uh,
any respectable standup comedian on the ground laughing this,
this fucking lady,
you know,
they do the usual shit.
You know,
when they get insulted when a guy in salt,
some they,
they do,
they basically,
females have like a,
okay.
I don't know,
for some reason they think of the very limited with their arguing ability.
Like if they get an argument with the guy,
then they're,
they're either going to attack your Dick size,
your sexuality or uh,
Oh yeah.
Or whatever.
So that's basically what this woman does.
She goes,
you know what,
I'm listening to you.
I bet you you,
you don't go out with any women.
You know,
she attacked him that way and he fucking,
he,
he brings the hammer down.
I don't condone what this guy does.
I actually think what he's doing is like a paint by numbers sort of shock.
There it is.
I challenge anyone to have a gay or a ringtone,
the net.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
check out that youtube video and a,
we've got a bunch of other funny ones where I'm actually just coming up on an
hour here.
I'm trying not to make these things too fucking long.
Let's,
let me just read a couple of more advice and then a couple more.
Is it racist?
He says.
All right,
here we go.
Bill.
Hi from Australia.
Uh,
I seem to share a lot of your views and I want some advice on women.
Jesus is all women's stuff.
Oh,
this week I'm supposed,
I'm only asking you because I want confirmation of my stance,
but who gives a shit?
Okay.
So generally,
uh,
so I generally look for value in things that I buy are things that I do with my
time.
I'm in my mid twenties,
and my parents,
um,
and my parents' friends put a lot of pressure on me to get a girlfriend.
I've had girlfriends and I always just got bored and sabotage it or fucked it up
somehow by not paying enough attention,
I pretty much decided that I want,
don't want to get married.
Everybody calling me boom,
ba,
ba boom,
ba boom.
Makes me feel important.
It feels like,
like announcement music.
Like I've just walked in and people are acknowledging.
I know.
I'm sorry.
I need to download a rig tone.
I should have the oh,
Jesus ringtone.
But I don't,
um,
anyways,
let's go back to this.
Um,
fucking sabotage shit.
To be honest,
I'd rather spend my money on myself and spend my time doing things I want to do.
Dude,
that's very,
it's very mature.
You know,
you,
all you're going to do is just end up hurting.
Somebody said,
yeah,
just bang them in and then leave that,
that hurts way less.
Especially,
especially if you're upfront.
Where does this go?
It's going nowhere,
sweetheart.
You'll want to ride it?
Nope.
Sorry.
Um,
as far as sex goes,
it takes too long.
What?
It's always worse than you thought it would be.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
I haven't read,
I haven't read any of these,
by the way,
and you're sweating your balls off under two feet of thermal blankets.
Dude.
You know you have the option to not have those blankets on.
Seriously,
what the fuck is it with women and the temperature?
I digress.
Basically I find women overall to be bad value.
There's two types of men as I see it,
those interrelationships that seem to be able to tolerate,
tolerate women and those that women won't go out with because they're ugly or
don't have enough money,
but I don't fit into either one of those groups.
I think I'm perfectly capable of acquiring or girlfriend,
but I just can't do it.
At least I can't be bothered maintaining a relationship.
I could see myself still being single at your age and was wondering how you've
dealt with people constantly nagging you about being single.
I can't really explain
that the world is overpopulated and I'd rather watch my big TV and peace without
some little annoying prick running around because then I'm labeled as some sort
of inhumane monster.
Any advice you can offer will be much appreciated.
You don't need any advice,
dude.
You know who you are and you know what you want.
Just continued doing it.
And you have to realize that,
uh,
people look out of their own heads,
you know,
that's so they see the world,
how they see it.
And when you don't see it the way they do,
they argue it or they,
they're just confused.
Uh,
you're not hurting anybody.
You don't,
there's people out there who get married because they're of a certain age,
like,
I should be getting married.
This is the age you get married.
They married somebody they're not in love with,
which is a fucking horrific thing to do to somebody a lot more.
I don't know.
There's a lot of people out there who shouldn't have kids.
They just fucking have kids and they're terrible fucking parents and their
selfish.
They'd rather sit around watching TV like me or go learn how to play drums like
me.
I am a selfish self centered cunt and a I w I,
you know,
I think I'd be a good dad at this point,
but,
um,
you know,
I was an angry fucking maniac when I was in my twenties.
You think I'm angry now?
Like this podcast would even have been funny in my twenties.
It would just be like Jesus,
dude.
Um,
you know,
when I would have brought a kid in the world then he would have been an angry
maniac.
So,
uh,
I dunno kind of bugs me that I waited this long,
but in general I'm kind of glad I did.
Um,
and what else if with that,
what the fuck was I going to read?
Oh,
I know.
It's a couple of oh,
Jesus ones and then we're out of here.
Where the hell,
how the hell do I get to this?
Ah,
you motherfucker.
While I'm trying to get to that,
I'm coming up.
I have,
um,
I'm getting,
I'm going to be at the,
uh,
the wise guys in Utah on a March 18th and 19th.
I have all that information up on my website,
[inaudible] dot com please show up for that show as is.
It's a nice quick flight and I would like to,
I like nice quick flights.
Makes me even funnier.
Right here we go.
Here we go.
Is it racist?
I haven't read this one at all.
So I have no fucking idea what this person's going to say.
So forgive me if this one,
because the really offensive ignorant ones I just don't read because I think
people are just fucking around or you're just beyond help.
All right.
Hey,
bill,
loved your podcast.
Love your comedy,
uh,
yet did at the day.
Here's what I want to ask.
If it could be race it's way I did.
When the team warms up in the shoot around,
uh,
I guess basketball,
they basically well shoot a route and it's always one or two white guys who are
not players.
The team managers or assistants who passed the balls back to the players when
they make or miss their shots.
But the white player who was suited up in uniform was standing next to the other
assistants or managers and was passing the ball out to the other black players
and he never got a chance to take a shot before the game started.
Considering every player on the team warmed up,
except for the white guy who was sitting in a lawn chair rebounding for every
other black player on the team.
Is it racist?
Keep up the great work.
Um,
okay.
No,
there's no racism going there.
He's either lazy or hurt or there's some sort of hazing going on.
He might be a rookie or he fucked up in the last game and that's his punishment.
Or maybe it was his turn.
I have no idea.
There's no racism going on there.
I don't think that they were saying,
uh,
you know,
do they have like a rally their team there and they just decided that,
uh,
that this guy could not shoot the fucking ball because he was white.
I mean,
you're really,
you're really stretching it
there.
I'll tell you though,
I did go,
I did daddy tell you guys this,
when I went to,
uh,
when I went to fucking,
that Portland Trailblazers game when I was with Paul Versey and we put money on
the trailblazers and they were making a comeback against New Orleans and they
came down the court in a fast break and they ditched it over to the white guy
and he fucking,
I can't remember,
he missed a dunk or whatever.
And the second he did it,
me and Paul both looked at each other and went to fucking white guy,
fucking white guy.
Why would you get out of the game,
put on a suit and fucking,
you know,
start drawing on that,
that little fucking legal pad or whatever the fuck is she supposed to be doing.
But you know,
our stay out on the perimeter,
don't try to take it to the fucking rack.
And if you do try to take it to the rack,
do at Pau Gasol does just start screaming like he just got raped because maybe
then you can take a couple of unguarded shots,
shots by the,
uh,
the foul line.
I'm telling you.
Watch your Lakers game anytime.
POW makes a move.
Oh,
is he goes there.
I just fucking hate that fucking white.
He's a great basketball player.
But that fucking,
what are you yelling about?
Sorry.
All right,
Bill.
Is it racist?
Um,
isn't racist for me to say all Asians are racist?
Uh,
yes,
I would think so.
I'm a white guy that happens to have dated a lot of Asian women of different
backgrounds from some from Asian,
some Asian Americans,
some actually born abroad,
all of whom were explicitly racist,
mostly against other Asian ethnicities.
For example,
my Korean x hates Japanese people.
A Chinese x hates Filipinos.
A Japanese x thinks the Chinese are stupid and the Thai Taiwanese or stuck up,
et cetera.
I should note that I didn't exclusively target Asian women to date.
I dated all sorts of women.
Some of them were Asian.
Uh,
my wife,
uh,
white girl thinks it's racist,
racist.
When I say that all Asians are racist.
Yeah.
Will it is dude,
I mean,
just cause the five that you banked.
how many,
you know what mean Asian women you would have to fuck and have that experience
with before you realize that now I'm not gonna sit here and try and pretend like
those groups get along with each other.
You know,
it's pretty safe to say any country that borders and other country,
they don't like them.
You know,
English England and Ireland,
England and France,
France and Germany,
Germany and everybody.
Japan,
Koreans,
Japan.
Where they did that.
I mean,
first of all,
I understand if a people in China have issues with people in Japan for what the
fuck they did during World War Two.
I read this book called the rape and Nan King.
I mean,
that alone,
it was just fucking brutal.
So I mean,
uh,
I dunno,
maybe,
maybe you,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
Maybe you just kept,
you know you don't,
when you keep dating women,
I mean woman's a psycho and then he kind of figure out that you keep picking
psychos.
Did you see,
I don't know.
That's kind of,
I'm kind of stretching it there.
How does that work that you just keep
somehow picking racist Asian women?
Were you attracted to them and it's fucking bizarre,
but I think,
yeah,
I think it is racist to say that you can't say,
you could say every Asian woman I dated was racist.
If that's what it was.
Okay.
I where the fuck knows.
Anyways,
hey bill as a fellow pasty white male dating a beautiful black woman.
I say racist shit all the time.
Really?
All right.
The n word is off limits,
but I do make fun of her for having the middle name La Fonts is that I said La.
I also tend to react to any stories on TV shows about young black males by
saying how hard it,
how hard it is for me to live my life as a strong black man.
And See,
this is the danger of not reading these up before I considered entering the Mr.
Black San Diego contest.
That would be funny.
I guess.
Am I racist?
I'm going to end up marrying this beautiful woman,
sorry about the comedy central show,
not working out.
If you're blah,
blah,
blah.
Ah,
is it racist?
I,
I'd have to hear how you doing it.
If you fucking around and you're being a Dick,
uh,
you,
you can be a dick.
Yeah.
I mean,
a lot of the shit that you said and now that I read it out loud on the podcast
probably would be considered racist or offensive and that type of thing.
It depends.
Is your girlfriend laughing?
You know,
I mean,
I,
I believe me,
the shit that comes out of my mouth when I watch TV,
every fucking thing you could think of.
I make fun of fucking everybody.
Um,
so I,
I if you,
if you're doing that like micro watches,
reality TV,
I fucking can't stand it.
Okay.
So I make fun of every God damn person on it.
And she laughed.
Sometimes other times she gets annoyed,
but the reason why she's getting annoyed is because of disrupting the show.
Not because I'm truly saying anything offensive,
but,
um,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
Is it,
is it racist that you're doing that?
I think she would say something.
You know,
I think the day she gets up and punches you in the face,
I think you're going to know or she really gets mad.
And if she really gets fucking mad,
then you have to realize that you're be,
that you're taking it beyond the point.
Uh,
and then also just because you have a black girlfriend,
you can't use that.
It'd be like,
well,
I have a black girlfriend.
I can't be racist.
Yes you can.
Yes,
you can.
Um,
you could still be fucked up,
you know?
Right.
You could have issues with,
but with other groups of people.
Jesus Christ,
I am,
I'm fucking sick of this topic.
I think this might be the last week of this fucking topic.
All right.
I've had an enormous,
maybe it's because I'm in a hotel room.
Well,
you can't open the fucking windows and it's 900 fucking degrees out.
Okay?
You know,
why can't I open the fucking windows and get fresh air in here instead of having
to turn on the God damn air conditioner.
Why the fuck can't I do that shit?
You know why?
Cause there's a bunch of sue happy fucking cuts out here,
which is why he can't open the fucking windows in a hotel room because they got
to worry that some Douche bag is going to get drunk and fall out or jump out
himself,
you know?
So then guys like me have to suffer.
It's the same fucking reason why you can't find a God damn hotel pool that's
deeper than three feet because some fucking asshole is going to get drunk and
drown himself in a legitimate deep end.
Oh,
here's something I learned and I actually tweeted about it like a fucking pussy
is um,
here's one for you.
Don't judge a hotel by its lobby.
All right?
It's the same thing is when you have a piece of shit car and you want to sell
it,
so you slap some rims on it,
you know,
or a high performance fucking exhaust system.
So it sounds like it has more power than it does.
All right.
Okay.
It's fucking,
yeah,
cause they,
they go all out with the lobby and then he put that shit on the website and you
think everything's fucking fine and dandy.
And then all of a sudden what happens?
You get in the God damn elevator and you step off the elevator and they have
that casino rug from fucking 1973 it looks like they sewed together like 12
Robin Williams fucking shirts.
Dude.
I have in my hotel,
I have an old school fucking,
what do you call the old or old tube?
It's not a flat screen.
Okay.
It's fucking ridiculous.
The amount of money.
I'm on Miami beach and I don't want to fucking talk about it.
Whatever.
All right.
That's the podcast for this God damn week.
People stopped suing people so we can have legitimate fucking pools.
Can you,
can you do that so he can open a hotel fucking window?
It's your fault if you fall out.
Okay.
It's your fault if your kid's a moron and you're not a good parent.
If the kid crawled away from you and fell out the fucking window,
what were you doing?
Huh?
Tie him down.
That's fucking brutal.
Um,
all right,
that's the podcast for this week.
I'm going to have hype some ups,
upcoming dates here.
Uh,
I'm like,
I never sweated during a fucking podcast before.
Suddenly ridiculously hot.
Um,
all right,
here we go.
Um,
and we get wise guys in West Valley City,
Utah.
Okay.
Um,
on March 18th and 19th,
which you guys think about that,
that kid on Byu,
sorry,
I had the hiccups.
The kid on Byu played on the basketball team and he admitted that he had
premarital sex,
knocked his girlfriend up,
said he was gonna marry her and they still kicked him off the team.
I've got to go with the college on that one.
Believe it or not.
You know,
they told you what the rules were.
If you didn't like the rules,
don't go to the fucking school.
You know?
That's like if I,
if I get booked on a corporate Gig,
I know I've used this example before and they said,
we want him to work totally clean.
This is how much we're going to pay.
And I say,
okay,
and then I show up and then I start dropping f bombs.
Right?
They're fucking,
did they have the right to get mad?
Don't take the fucking Gig.
Don't go to Byu Byu.
If you want some pussy this,
they,
they make you sign a no pussy contract.
Don't sit there and act surprised and all these other fucking assholes who
aren't Mormons with 32 wide.
That's why they,
that's why they marry so many fucking women,
by the way.
It's that they're trying to make up for those college years when they didn't get
the fuck,
you know,
and now because they're married,
they can have a fucking orgy.
Can you imagine that?
That would be,
that would probably,
do you think that would be worth it?
And I know the old joke,
Jesus Christ,
you can't even put a warm,
warm welcome for,
you know,
actually the reality is she just get,
a couple of call girls and do that,
pay him and then just have him fucking leave.
Right.
That's probably what you should do.
But if you had four fucking wives,
that would be great.
You would win every argument unless they all banded together,
then you'd be in trouble.
Okay?
Oh Jesus.
You could do a lot of pimp shit to start,
you know,
to gain even more control.
You could just,
you know,
the ones that are the weakest one,
you start treating her the best cause she's doing all the good shit.
Then you break down the other ones,
you know,
do you get them in line?
Then they look like once you know these proud
free mustangs running in the wind,
now they're just sitting there with their heads looking down at the coppers.
They bring you over TV dinner.
I think I'm gonna move to Utah.
Um,
I'm also going to be at the,
uh,
I'm going to be at the Ritchie Reci or theater in Maryland on April 8th,
and I'm going to be at the a tower theater in Philadelphia on April the ninth.
Um,
all these dates are on bill [inaudible] dot com and uh,
that is that,
that is,
that is the podcast for this week.
I hope all you guys,
uh,
hope you enjoyed it.
I hope you learn some things.
I hope,
I hope I annoyed some pot heads out there.
Potheads I'm just fucking around it,
right?
Smoke it every God damn day.
I don't give a shit.
All right,
but don't give me this horse shit that it's not addicting.
Alright.
You smoke it because you can't fucking deal.
I shouldn't even tell you this story.
I had a buddy of mine,
he was fucking,
he was working at a car dealership one time and he got high and there was
somebody looking at a car.
Oh honey.
You know,
and they were bent down in front of the car and he got in the car and it was a
stick shift.
And he didn't press in the clutch and he turned the key and it alerts 40 hit the
guy right in the head.
Okay.
And He tried to act.
He would never admit that he was high.
It was like,
dude,
it was,
he goes,
he calls me up,
right?
He's like,
dude,
he leaves a message.
He's whispering.
That's how fucking scared he is.
He's whispering into my phone.
Maybe he's at work.
I don't know.
Saying,
dude,
I,
I hit somebody with a car,
dude.
Aye.
I thought I had the car,
dude.
Dude,
I,
I thought I had the car in neutral dude.
And I,
I went to turn the key and it,
dude,
I hit the guy in the head,
dude to call me.
Somehow he didn't get fired.
Uh,
that's another reason why I think weed is worse than booze.
People that you know,
you can get fucking high at work.
No one fucking knows.
No one knows,
you know,
little visor,
a little fucking gum.
No one knows,
right?
You guys are bringing down this country with your fucking cookies.
You realize that you're a bunch of Lazy Dorita wheat and sons of bitches.
Okay?
Just sitting there getting baked.
Do you realize that you'll potheads of the reason why so many awful movies get
made?
Cause they know,
they know people out there a smoking dope and then when they put it out on on,
they're going to fucking
rent it.
And it doesn't only ways to be like remotely funny and then Shit that wasn't
even supposed to be funny.
It's going to be funny because he's fucking pot heads are going to be sitting
there.
They're going to be high giggling
like a bunch of school girls.
You know,
you pot has got a lot of fucking balls.
You realize that
you fucking disgusting fucking habit.
Passing it around to each other.
It's white.
That's what is.
There's so many goddamn cold sores out there.
You know the number one cause of cold sores in this country.
It's you fucking potheads passing the things around each other.
Do you realize that?
You know,
I'm real cracking open a beer.
I don't remember passing it around and nine other fucking people.
Hey,
let me get a swig of that.
Open your own.
You can't.
That's why I like weed,
man.
It's more social.
Yeah,
go fuck yourself.
Did you go to take a fucking shower and take off those goddamn outback pants?
All right,
I'm sick of all right.
With your bracelet around your ankle.
All right.
You're not more in touch with nature because you're smoking trees.
All right?
Get out there.
Get a fucking job.
Straighten up.
Potheads you just spent the last decade of your life on a fucking couch.
You know,
when are you gonna put your helmet on?
Getting the Goddamn game.
So what you're gonna do,
you're gonna sit there
like some kept woman,
Cynthia kept by yourself and you're fucking awful habit.
I got to get high,
dude.
I can't deal unless I'm high.
You know you can really going to sit there and act like you don't know that guy.
How come all they talk about is the alcoholics.
This is like the fucking broads.
All they do is talk about wife beaters,
but they never bring up gold digging horse.
Why don't you fucking get your God damn fucking pothead ass up off the couch and
go look in the fucking mirror?
Look,
look what you're doing to yourself.
Look at your eyes.
Feel how your brain feels compressed.
I'm looking down,
my alkie knows it all.
You fucking potheads.
There is a reason why weed is illegal and alcohol isn't all right cause alcohol
is better for you.
Alcohol is what a man does.
All right.
We'd is what some pussy does.
Who,
who can't afford to pay for a good pizza?
So he's got a fucking get himself so fucking disoriented that that's how
Domino's survives.
Those fucking assholes.
Do you know Domino's makes such shitty pizza that actually potheads even fucking
noticed.
You realize that.
So they actually had to have an ad campaign where they fucking admit that their
pizza sucks and that it's stuck to the top of the box and it's completely
unacceptable,
right?
And now they're big ad campaign is we,
uh,
we admit that our pizza sucks and now we're going to start trying.
We've only been around for what,
30 fucking years now we're actually going to to make decent pizza.
Right?
So you think automatically they're going to raise the price.
They're going to add to the quality.
This still selling like a large cheese pizza for five 99.
All right.
People,
you get what you pay for.
All right?
Don't order Domino's.
That's pothead pizza.
That's what those fucking drug users,
that's what,
that's,
that's what they,
they stick in their temple.
All right.
That's why they're so fucking dumb.
That's why it was the last time you talked to a smart pot head.
Have you ever,
you ever seen a pothead with initiative?
You know,
you know people are going to take that seriously and start sending me fucking
emails about,
uh,
well what about Bob Marley bed?
Well,
we fucking go new kind of music,
man.
He was fucking dead.
A lung cancer,
you know,
from smoking goddamn joints the size of a bus exhaust.
It's no different,
no different than a booze hound or drinks himself to death at 28.
You know,
I think you know,
I think your part as you guys have been on your high horse long enough,
I think it's time I fucking knocked you off a little bit.
Even going to notice you probably already off the horse laying in the grass,
right?
Letting a breeze go through your toes.
Is that what you did today?
Instead of going out and earning your fucking rent,
you've got to call your parents up again this week.
Hit him up with some more money because you ran out of fucking Cheetos.
Huh?
You're too fucking old to have a full body.
Tim.
Why don't you go get a God damn job.
You son of a bitch.
All right.
There you go.
Once a week.
I got to try to piss off one group,
but keeps the emails coming.
Um,
all right,
that's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
I want to thank everybody,
Sarah scene.
I'm not fucking around here like I was with the potheads there,
right?
So fucking don't get all fucking pissed off me.
And,
um,
I want to thank everybody who came out to my shows at the,
uh,
the Miami Symphony fucking,
Superman's house.
It's really what it looked like.
Um,
and I really hope a bunch of people show up in Utah,
uh,
and don't be,
don't be stuck up.
Cons,
all right?
With your fucking religion.
Okay.
I,
I don't need that.
I don't need you and your seven wives sitting there staring at me like I got a
fucking problem.
All right.
Fuck you.
And your legal orgy.
Okay.
I think that's it.
All right.
That's a podcast.
Everybody go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.
Have a good week.
Don't talk any shit.
I'll talk some shit.
Don't take any shit.
There we go.
That's it.
I'm going to go get a sunburn.
I'll see you.
You want and go.
And just to gather right
the way we
would you mind
sharing?
Yeah.